we have a brand new fox poll tonight as
well showing 87 percent of registered
voters are extremely or very concerned
about inflation and higher prices
meanwhile 76 percent care about deep
political divisions and almost at the
very bottom of the list if you can look
down that far only 65 percent are
concerned about infrastructure so
why is that the only thing joe biden and
the democrats seem to care about it's
like they flip the poll
upside down here now newt gingrich
former speaker of the house he's also
got a new book beyond biden out on
november 2nd you can pre-order your copy
now
on amazon new glad to have you so
you can see what's important to
americans
why is the bite administration
uninterested in those issues
well that's true across the board
they're uninterested in
controlling the border which is a huge
issue for americans they're uninterested
in the rise in murders which is a big
issue to americans you have does a whole
list of things
the biden team which includes
schumer and pelosi and virtually every
democrat in washington except maybe
mansion and cinema
the biden team
is committed to a a hard left
big government socialist model
they have to pay off the unions that
means they've got to pass big spending
they've got to find ways to take care of
their allies
and i think that you see them
literally tone deaf i mean
i actually don't have the language
and i've been working on this these are
people who reject reality i mean it's
not that
you know reagan used to say he didn't
worry about what liberals didn't know he
worried about what they knew that wasn't
true well now i'm worried because even
when it's objectively obvious i mean
they're flying
children at night into westchester
county new york getting them out of
texas
and i don't think anybody knows where
they're going what's happening to them
and the white house is just totally out
of touch with reality and frankly so is
the democratic party in the house and
the senate
hey new we'll have to have a longer
conversation about this because i'm
fascinated by what you just said i
struggled with the language as well i
think what it is they're developing a
pseudo reality they've been living in a
reality they've manipulated so
successfully there's no need to adapt to
what they think is the real reality
there's much more here newt but i need
to ask you about a news story as well
new report out the democratic donors see
at least this reality joe biden has no
future politically
kamala harris has no future politically
and democratic donors are now looking to
pete buddha judge as the possible future
maybe as early as 2024. how's that for
reality newt
well you've got in buda judge somebody
who took two months off on family leave
leaving behind nobody in charge of the
department of transportation as we
drifted into a gigantic uh crisis of
logistics with over 60 ships stuck
offshore from long beach for example off
of a savannah off of los angeles so
we're going to take a guy who's a total
failure at solving one of the biggest
economic problems we have right now and
we're going to somehow magically make
him the democratic nominee i mean as a
republican i think it's terrific but i
think as a matter of back to what we
said a minute ago as a matter of reality
how could you take this guy who's
utterly irresponsible
and who there's a certain level where
family leave doesn't quite work like if
you're in charge of the whole country's
transportation system and he didn't
leave anybody in charge so for two
months we were rudderless had nobody in
charge and the entire logistics system
got steadily worse as we're going to
discover at christmas
yeah
i guess to sympathize with him a little
bit newt i don't know where else they
will turn i don't know where to go biden
harris buddha judge good luck i don't
know where you go they've got they've
got lots of they've got lots of people
they've got senators they got governors
they got movie stars you know somewhere
that's true they do have movie stars
there's somebody
there's somebody better than pete
judge a fair point all right newt i look
forward to talking to you more in the
future we have a little more time in a
little more depth hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else